seven injured after a shooting on  highway 95 in henderson yesterday  afternoon six were taken to sunrise  hospital two in critical condition it's  still unclear who was involved in sunday  afternoon shooting but highway 95 going  northbound it was shut down for several  hours it was just a mess people forced  to take alternate routes causing some  major traffic delays  trying to go back to las vegas and i  have a flight to catch it's been over an  hour to try and get three miles and no  we haven't talked to anybody else just  trying to stay patient it's terrible we  all need to go to the bathroom and we  can't we can't because we're all stuck  here  anderson police have not yet confirmed  the circumstances leading up to the  shooting as they are still looking for  the suspects involved